want to see something worse no
the boy is over a fighter in the kid
let's go back to more
drinks i'm sure there's got to be more
drinking
yeah but i want drinks presented to me
by people less cringe
so um
they're talking about i hope they're
talking about
releasing a deadly nerve gas into the
room
no there this is worse they're talking
about why does pete davidson get so much
hate
oh is that touchy too touchy no pete
davis is not touchy
no no no it's um because do you remember
when i was i was defending pete
whenever i have interaction with pete
davidson right he's always so nice to me
he's a good guy
and we exchanged numbers we take back a
little back and forth
and then i was talking i was like god
why do people give that guy so much [ __ ]
just because he's [ __ ] all these so
let me get this straight let me get this
straight
the fact that you have pete davidson's
number and you guys have texted back and
forth a couple of times
completely makes him exempt to all
criticism i just want to make sure that
that's the that's the position we're
taking yes but remember this is the same
this is the same brandon shob that
because uh shane gillis did a ching
chong joke
said he wasn't funny and uh should have
been fired but but that aside
that this is gonna be his cause he's
done this before his stances i've met
pete davidson before he's nice we texted
a couple of times
i don't understand why people criticize
him at all because he texted me a couple
times like
what he's talented and all that stuff
and then a bunch of people dm and i was
like dude ash
boy chris why he gets so much hate and
that so i was like
i didn't even i was like why the [ __ ] i
think it's back
open your mouth when you talk you
[ __ ] caveman
brendan schaub talks like he's still
actively getting punched in his face as
he's talking
brendan shop talks like he every day he
just got a root canal
dude so i text chris randomly because i
watch pete's special
dude what [ __ ] people hate on this
guy well the thing is
that's crazy i i just got in trouble for
this yesterday
chevy chase is really funny but
everybody hates him because he's a piece
of [ __ ] human being like
yeah and then there's pete davidson who
everybody hates and he's also not funny
right so two things again it's like
different things that people have
careful uh well no in trouble for no no
because uh
no p the thing is first of all i haven't
seen or spoken to pete in years give
your history with people
people why don't you let the guy answer
a [ __ ]
no but yo but like what is your problem
okay so here's the thing so the thing is
with pete
yeah but what is like why is everybody
so like weird about it no it's funny you
asked that
was this one because i talk to pete all
the time like he texts me and [ __ ] like
i met him at the store and he's really
cool guys well it's okay so this one
time i was on the set of this movie so
you had like a problem
with with pete davidson yeah brendan so
here's the thing to answer your question
so i was one time
is that what you think comedy is i think
comedy is
i'm leaving yo check out my sneakers
look at my legs papa
papa
i swear to god i'm still waiting for
brendan brendan the other day did that
clip he showed with him and uh
uh joel mchale doing the lay down thing
reminded me of the doink the clown
mirror
spot at wrestlemania what
[Laughter]
someone pointed out why is brennan
dressed like che guevara
about to start a cte revolution
seriously
he's dressed like che guevara but he has
the sexual uh habits of raul castro
but he's dressed like people that che
guevara killed exactly
people understand pete no seriously pete
davidson like to me
i consider him like a friend like i
don't know i don't know i have no i'm
not a part of pete's life
but i like being friends with that's me
i consider him a friend that i just said
i haven't spoken to in years right
real friends friends guys you should be
like we used to be real close so we have
to be real close
um we haven't spoken in years but i
still consider him a friend
because we both have to work in this
business and i don't want to get [ __ ]
gigs pulled away from me
just say that yo b you know who's an
unfunny hack now
louis ck cause he like can't help me in
my career yo but that's what i mean
you see how he does that like ah look
man i don't wanna
figure i haven't spoken to peter in
years but i consider him a friend and we
used to be inseparable
we were like best friends now we haven't
spoken in years but he's still a friend
like it's so
[ __ ] i hate these people man uh but
i don't you know to me that was how many
years ago yeah [ __ ]
oh my god let him talk
now i'm getting mad let him talk this is
getting
really bad okay i'm sorry
dude through this whole mess are you
noticing number one how brian call in a
city number two he takes his shoes off
number three's playing with his feet
i wanna he's playing with he's sitting
crisscross applesauce playing with his
feet
wearing justin trudeau socks brian
callan has the body language of a
six-year-old
yeah really right that you had to bring
to work because your wife is in the
hospital or something and now
he's just bouncing around on the chairs
and they want to sit
in the shopping cart not in the seat
that they're supposed to sit in you're
like i have to put food in it
please whatever eight years ago so
people on the internet
at the time leave your feet alone he's
still
interrupting him no there's so much he's
still interrupting him you know what's
great about these videos
five people could watch it and we could
all pick up on completely different
things that are annoying just go back
like four seconds i
want you to see he just keeps talking
over him
here you go yo to me that was how many
years ago yeah [ __ ]
whatever eight years ago so people on
the internet yeah at the time
that's the thing that's all it doesn't
make sense and then [ __ ] i don't get it
just doesn't
it's like he's [ __ ] with him like
that's the kind of thing if you told me
that like if i actually believe brennan
child was funny
and it was like they had somebody on you
were just doing like that would be
hilarious if you were doing it as a bit
you're like we'll bring in a guest and
we'll just keep interrupting them we'll
see how long they'll last before they
just snap on us
the way back in 2014 people are like he
was 19. you knew what happened
shut up shut up
and yeah so yeah basically no it was
just like it was just one of those
things where it's like
again i'm just telling the story because
you asked but i [ __ ] love
i i whatever i would be pete's friend i
feel like i am
friend i just thought you were but now
you are i thought you were friends with
him
don't see the guy anymore you're just
both busy you don't have to get into the
story no no
the whole point was to get into the
story you set up the story
you [ __ ] nitwit i swear to god if
chris if christy stefano just got up and
brendan schrub's throat right now you'd
be an american hero
and honestly look i don't even mind
chris i don't stephan doesn't really
bother me
at all like i'm just when he's there to
me but very indifferent to him
it's not a good sign for being in the
comments no i get it but
anybody in this position whether he was
best friends brendan
set up a story instead of sitting down
there and doing all right so you tell us
about it
he has to interrupt and interject what
what are you nervous i'm not trying to
shame
no we're not trying to shame pete yeah i
don't i you will shame shane gillis
though and you will shame other people
you don't like
you will shame them though again i just
don't know but i think the reason why
people are messaging you about that
or you know whatever is because these
[ __ ] internet fans
uh which thanks thank you um pete
um when we he was 19 i was like
27 and these [ __ ] internet fans
hey listen losers listen you little
pieces of [ __ ]
my and a girl that i was dating was was
like 23 and then we we
me and the girl broke up and then and
then it was fully broken up
and then and then uh and then pete just
and we were all friends and then pete
you know after we broke up was like
started dating that girl
and so but i was pete's friend and then
they had a good relationship whatever
i mean especially if you guys were all
friends we were all
why friends but soldiers
let him finish the first point
before you get to the second point
i despise brendan schaub at this point
he just won't let anyone spit and they
put this up as a clip
yeah they thought this was good a point
called guy code
so all the guy code things like you
broke i code pete you broke up
why are you friends with a 19 year old
when you're 27 that's weird right
the comics are degenerates there's not
in the comedian world there's not much
difference in lifestyle from a 19 year
old than a 27 year old
it's not like anybody like cheated on
anybody was like we broke up you were
all friends
and and why does chris over here have a
wearing first baseman pants
me and the girl broke up and then pete
dated her later and then pete
apologized to me like six months after
everything pete was like hey i shouldn't
have done that
i was wrong while you were still dating
her all good all good man
so so but i think but like i think the
fan i think that's why if you're asking
me that
question that's why the fans would
that's why they say because they don't
know they don't they don't have a reason
i don't think anyone can come up with a
reason shut
the [ __ ] up brendan
shut up shut up the speech the speech
therapy is really paying off huh
he's a good guy end of the day well
that's fine how do you
know but like so i don't get all these
guys do this
they all do he's a good guy he's a
stand-up guy
he's a good dude how do you know but
this this is when you see these comics
and i don't mean to harp on this but
this is really something that i think
is a bigger picture when it comes to
some la comics specifically but
a lot of comics you see this this
mentality of
what can they do for me now pete is a
star
i hate him but he is got a netflix
special people love him everybody's
talking about pete davidson whether it's
good or bad everybody know who pete is
right
that's why they're being nice to him
it's the same reason other comics are
nice to brendan it's it's the same
it's this this ecosystem where they take
care of each other
a couple years two years ago mike louis
ck
all of these people would have been
sucking his dick sucking his
ginger [ __ ] while he told him not to
leave the hotel room
um they would have been sucking his dick
but they were still sucking up to him
even when the allegations started coming
out and then when it became clear okay
you're out you remember when jim norton
was like i don't know man
i can't defend that i can't defend that
yeah jim norton remember that remember
that girl that he took advantage of
during the jagermeister machine day
the intern oh no remember the girl that
came with that band oh yeah yeah yeah
they had the jaeger machine and he
[ __ ] her and she was drinking underage
in the studio and then they had to erase
that show from everyone's memory
and they got rid of the aeger machine
remember that guys remember the show
that nobody can talk about
i remember you know
so i think i think with pete but yeah i
i wish i would see pi just
the thing is when these guys get on snl
like you know pete and michael chan you
they're so busy that you don't see him
anymore you know you talk from him and
you said
what's he saying is he saying words or
just mumbling
but like he's terrible
all day every day you know so otherwise
they get written off the show are fired
yeah so i don't so i don't when they
drop into the comedy cell we all say
hello and hang out
but for the most part yeah i don't i
don't see them it's very funny i've
never seen this yeah
there it is very funny guy i've never
seen anything he's done but
very funny dude maybe he means on snl
he's not funny on us
of course what did he mean i don't
i don't uh yeah i don't know we'll see i
mean [ __ ]
i think we'll see what what i mean we'll
see is something gonna happen
this is this is what happens when nobody
wants to be at a place and they're all
having a conversation nobody wants to be
having at least joel mchale laid down
and was like oh my god what am i doing
here
about how hard it's got to be imagine
yeah joel mchale that [ __ ]
christy stefano very good point like
what is this guy done [ __ ]
fighter and the kid in the opie radio
podcast
what is cr what is chris d stefano's
biggest [ __ ]
part of his resume the guy from opie
radios
the guy from opie's podcast that's still
alive is that going to be his biggest
that's a shrinking window big claim to
famous oh yeah i'm the white guy from
the opie podcast that didn't die
yeah yeah that's a good point like
people are saying with the pete davidson
he made people sign an nda before his
comedy special that is true
and i had people defending him going oh
it was a bit no he really made them sign
ndas that wasn't a bit
at young and getting pushed into the
spot like that quick
and why did it happen for him that greek
obviously he's super talented but
who discovered him because he was how
old when he's like seven 20 years old
but something when he started doing
stand up right oh yeah oh yeah no when
pete yeah he was young
he started 16 what perspective do you
have at 16. he was good what perspective
do you have in comedy
when your only thing in it is have been
punched in the head a bunch of times by
ufc fighters
and being joe rogan's friend like what
perspective do you have
going into comedy at 16 is the same
thing as having a 16 year old's brain
brendan good well he got a lie me and
his dad died
so he went through what this is the
first time hearing wait look that up
look that up did he really die
dad die in 11.
that's never brought up
[Laughter]
a lot of people's dads died on some [ __ ]
that's true so so he was like one of
those like
he went through some pain already oh my
god land is right bin laden is
responsible for pete davidson well saudi
arabia
yeah seriously well that's what's funny
because they're like well who discovered
pete davidson muhammad atta
so i think that's what it is with with
peta where was pete discovered again
uh united flight 175. nice
nice yeah he was just good at it at a
young age but
you know i guess at times suffers from
depression and stuff
i to be honest with you anything that
the public knows about pete that's what
i know about pete cause i just don't but
i thought you were friends
they were best friends royce they're
still friends
i thought so are you friends or do you
only know what the public knows like
there's a lot going on here is pete
davidson the worst thing to come out of
he's up there right number two patriot
acts number one but then pete's number
i don't know man if he sticks around
much longer you're right
all right oh you know again i would i'm
just
you know like you just lose touch with
people i just don't i'm sure i don't see
or talk
about i think pete probably is harder on
himself
than anybody else needs to be no pete's
harder on louis ck than anybody else for
the most part
sure you know that's what what i gather
if i don't know anything about him but
it it he seems like a good guy funny
talent he's telling me
yeah he got off callan hasn't talked
this whole time
so callum finally goes to talk and he
interrupts him interrupting him
immediately immediately you want to talk
about a big [ __ ] dick
back energy he started big dick yeah
that's all he cares about pete first off
it's weird but pete davidson started big
dick energy really it was pete davidson
that that term never was around before
pete davidson he
he co-opted it but he didn't start that
the internet like everything started
that
he's got a piece kid's got a pup papa
piece
so like you're not really close friends
but you know what his dick looks like
well all these comedians i don't know
what it is but they all talk about each
other's dicks you notice that
it's the weirdest [ __ ] thing i think
he might be 10
no warts and clean shafts and they're
saying it's circumcised
and circumcised because he's from he's a
a white kid from staten island so those
kids
yeah i don't think you can leave the
hospital unless you without the foreskin
yeah you come out with the foreskin
yeah no good it's catholic it's kind of
yeah it's santa yeah apparently he has
just that big dick
energy i'd love to he already said that
brendan but it's like almost like you
already said that brendan it's almost we
heard you bro
it's like almost like he has big dick
energy
you've never seen it i'd give it a twirl
no he wouldn't pull he was well he was
that's another that's one of the
honestly thing that i do get upset about
most of pete is because
he was 16 17 years old when we stopped
really being friends so like
you know he was i didn't get a chance to
look at this i thought he was 19.
now he's 16 17 now bro he's jumping
around like tarantino
minor but i wish he was 18 because i
would have demanded to see his penis
yeah
comedy guys comedy folks i like comedy
no it's new yorkers too opie oh jim
norton
and those guys started the hole oh he's
got a big dick on him i've seen his dick
before that was
always the o and a crowd that did that
[ __ ] cuz all these guys are [ __ ] on a
offshoots you know i would have i would
be like hey you got to fight me to get
out of this doorway unless you put your
dick now big dick energy's gone it's
it's big dick
spirit is he trying to start something
look everybody's having a different
convert notice there's three people in
that room and they're all having
completely different conversations
i i it's upsetting to me
it's big dicks yeah tall kid how tall is
he tall he's tall
tall tall uh drink of water paul oh my
god are you guys gonna
get it over with and just [ __ ] them
already
the the title of this video is why did
pete davidson get so much hate
but they are they ever gonna get into
that cause there's only two minutes left
here folks
three six four see and guys like that
like like thinner guys
like that yeah you get [ __ ] hit with
an elbow like that you're gonna get
knocked unconscious
he'll split open an eye pete davidson
pete davidson's gonna beat somebody up
seriously
sure you know i don't like to fight a
skinny mini like raw bone i call him
wrong weird says six one call him he's
smaller than that no no pdd
is way tall pd pd mike
now he sounds like like he's a member of
third base i'd rather hear petey pablo
do stand up
definitely
real nice lineup he does well what does
he look like i mean what's he
what does he look like i don't know like
his [ __ ] like pete davidson
looking at a photograph of him you dumb
[ __ ] it's his nationality he's good
i don't know actually he looks almost
like he's ambiguous yeah
he's italian and jewish it's pretty
pretty standard
the good old pdt yeah jewish is this a
[ __ ]
mystery you know hope he's doing well
american sounds like he's doing well oh
yeah i was gonna say yeah
yeah sounds like he's doing well he's
been to rehab 40 47 different times
he lives in his mother's basement with
well he gets homemade tattoos yeah
sounds like he's emotionally doing well
sounds like an emotional person
emotionally just set for life netflix
special snl help
me i hope he's doing well i'm [ __ ]
taking spirit airlines to vegas in an
hour
no he's jewish it's jewish is he jewish
he's jewish
yeah i was right brian oh there you go
okay his father was jewish yeah yeah
weird how he got into show business
mother's irish jewish my friends
catholic
and irish i wonder what that means
what i guess jews go to heaven right
what's the matter
what is this what what are we watching
is this is this their show yeah they
talk about big dicks
this is a seven minute clip five minutes
of it's been pete davidson's penis
uh there's no heaven in the old
testament okay did you know that oh
that's right when you die
of the earth yeah you're you just have
you know moses and abraham they all
lived you know
in the bible 250 years and [ __ ] had
tons of kids right now yeah yeah good
good good [ __ ] clip
this show's on fire i wish he was on
fire
if you watched if you watch this show
like if you're a fan of the show
i cannot respect you i want you to know
this i cannot respect you